I'm itchy this morning but my name again
is Dan McIntyre I'm the associate dean
for academic affairs you probably
remember this morning the Dean said that
Matt Clemens was in charge of ensuring
that the rain would stay away so Matt
you're going to have to turn it off by
to 15 or so because at that point I
understand you leave this building and
move or at least some of you across the
campus so Matt will be taking care of
that or else securing a lot of umbrellas
for you it's my great pleasure to
introduce one speaker on our program
today who needs no introduction here at
Columbia University we know him as the
quitte let professor of sustainable
development and professor of Health
Policy and management and we know him as
the director of the Earth Institute the
interdisciplinary global research center
focused on solving the most pressing
problems facing the world's people and
environment he's also a special adviser
to United Nations secretary-general ban
ki-moon
from 2002 to 2006 he was the director of
the UN Millennium Project and special
adviser to United States
secretary-general Kofi Annan on
Millennium Development Goals those of
you who enroll at SEPA this fall in the
MIAA program will no doubt read great
considerable portion of his recent book
Commonwealth economics for a crowded
planet and those of you who don't enroll
in that program I still recommend the
book to you in which he describes the
multiple potential crises facing the
world growing economic disparity between
the poorest and the wealthiest and even
the middle-income nations deepening
environmental crisis and a still
expanding population in the book he
makes the case for strong policy changes
to put the world on the path toward what
he refers to as sustainable development
there's one more really important thing
that I always like to say about Jeff
Sachs he is indeed as you know a world
recognized researcher policy advisor to
leaders of Nations but he's also
dedicated to teaching here at Columbia
University he not only leads a large
undergraduate course in sustainable
development he is the founding
co-director of the Columbia University
ph.d program in sustainable development
he founded the program here at Seba
another program here at SEPA the MPA and
development practice and he teaches each
year to leads to SEPA courses on
development and sustainable development
issues he is extremely generous with his
time with students and whenever we here
at SEPA have a need in a program for
someone to give a keynote address
whenever Jeff is available he is here to
speak to us so ladies and gentlemen it's
my great pleasure to give to you Jeff
Sachs
hi everybody I can keep it very brief
you should definitely come seriously any
questions it this is a phenomenal
University a phenomenal school a unique
City and a great time to be at SEPA so
that's why I'm here and I think the
reasons are are really compelling and
frankly we're at a very remarkable time
in the world you're going to be the
people that are gonna have to sort all
this out because even though you've been
sitting at the tables working on energy
and environment and human rights and
economic policy you probably haven't
solved everything yet this morning the
world's problems are getting more and
more complicated the capacity of our
political systems under their
traditional structures to solve these
problems is obviously diminishing
rapidly this country's in a kind of
nervous breakdown politically it seems
absolutely unable to do anything except
stagger from one day to the next and I
think it's because we have unique very
complicated growing problems and
institutions which are not properly
organized for the challenge and a new
set of complexities that our current
leaders have not been trained to solve
one of the problems we work on a lot is
climate change there are two approaches
to climate change one is the US Congress
approach which is to deny that it's a
problem that definitely is the simplest
solution except it's not going to make
the planet any safer and the other is to
delve into what is without question the
most complicated public policy challenge
that the world has ever faced because to
really address a problem like
climate change means to understand how
energy is at the core of the world
economy to understand how technology and
even basic science that need to be
cooperative and coordinated around the
world to understand how one can
implement at a global scale a directed
process of change that it will have to
be of a magnitude and speed that's
unprecedented in human effort and of
course we're not doing a very good job
of it and nature is only paying
attention to the rise in greenhouse gas
concentrations and the planets getting a
lot more dangerous very rapidly
well I think that SEPA is a unique place
to be working on these problems and it's
really the essence of the approach that
the University and the school are taking
and the essence of the approach that the
earth Institute is taking we start from
the premise that we are at a new
juncture of history this isn't really
about book learning of traditional
solutions this is about a juncture in
the world that is taking us into
absolutely uncharted territory we will
have by next year seven billion people
on the planet will have a world economy
that is absolutely spilling over the
biophysical constraints whether its
climate whether its ocean acidification
whether its destruction of biodiversity
whether its increasing scarcity of water
whether it's a growing global food
crisis we are bursting at the seams
we've never had a problem like this the
u.s. role in the world is changing and I
would say in relative terms diminishing
in terms of leadership very rapidly
while there is no coherent cooperative
replacement yet obviously China's rising
tremendously and importance India is
rising tremendously important importance
the demography of the Middle East is at
a pace of change
that those societies can't absorb but
that will change the face of global
politics as well and that have played a
big role in the upheavals in recent
weeks the institutions that we have
globally to deal with this at the UN
where I work many days each week are
absolutely stuck in in important ways in
20th century structures that have to be
changed for 21st century problem solving
and so we start from the premise that we
need a university and a way of thinking
and a way of problem solving that makes
breakthroughs and that is up to today's
challenges and that can't rely on
traditional approaches whether to
concepts or to pedagogy itself and I
think that what this means is that
universities need to change dramatically
and I'm very satisfied that as hard as
that is because universities are among
society's longest lasting institutions
they're really remarkable creations they
last hundreds or even thousands of years
which is pretty tough in this world but
we're at a time where universities need
to change tremendously and we have a
leadership at this university that is
committed to that and I find it
exhilarating and very exciting and very
promising not that anybody knows exactly
what to do because we're all good
groping as well in how to be effective
and how to make sure that the role of
the university is evolving rapidly in
line with the changing world and
changing world's needs and changing
needs for you to get the kind of
education that will enable you to be
world leaders but I feel that with
president Bollinger --zz vision of
Colombia as a great global University
and with the my good friend Dean
cotesworth John cotesworth the vision of
SEPA as being the preeminent place to
study public
see in this rapidly changing global
sphere and with the perch that I'm very
lucky to have at the earth Institute
which is a remarkable initiative of this
University which decided almost 15 years
ago now that problems of sustainable
development population poverty a planet
exploding in resource use climate change
and so forth needed to be put at the
forefront of thinking in a
university-wide cross-disciplinary
manner when you put those pieces
together what we have is an institution
that I believe is at the cutting edge of
thinking about these problems teaching
about them researching them and doing
something about them and I believe that
that doing part is a critical
distinctive characteristic of Columbia
and has to be a critical distinctive
characteristic of any great University
in the 21st century there is no division
anymore between the study and the
research on the one side and then people
going out to do things the universities
have to be actively engaged in problem
solving for two reasons one is that you
can't understand the problems without
being engaged in them in an absolutely
sleeves rolled up intensive way and
second the universities have unique
characteristics the kind of range of
knowledge the students the fresh
insights that you bring that make
universities uniquely capable of solving
some of the problems that our
governments absolutely are incapable
right now of solving so every time that
Columbia in the nearly 10 years that
I've been here has looked at one of
these challenges it stepped forward it
stepped up it said we've got to be
engaged and we've got to be engaged in a
very serious way we'll put on new degree
programs we'll put on new field work new
global research centers new partnerships
with the United Nations new partnerships
with foreign governments new
partnerships with the world NGOs new
partnerships with local communities
doing things that are really very
unusual very much pushing the envelope
but we better be doing that because I
don't think we have time to time despair
I'm having a great time here by the way
also and I think you will as well these
new programs offer tremendous
opportunities one of the fun
exhilarating difficult challenging
complicated nerve-wracking parts of our
program is something that some of you
may have heard of but I'll just give it
as one example as the Millennium
villages program which is a program that
is addressing extreme poverty and an
integrated holistic high-technology
manner across now about 15 countries in
Africa and this is a program which is
engaging not only the earth Institute
scientists the local communities the
national governments the UN agencies our
engineer our engineering students who
are coming up with the dazzling work but
a tremendous number of SEPA students who
are engaged in all kinds of problem
solving data analysis surveying
community engagement looking at new
institutional solutions across all of
the sectors that were working in
agriculture public health education and
so on we have as Dan just mentioned a
wonderful new program the Masters in
development practice it has a feature
which i think is going to become
absolutely part of our daily lives for
all of you and for us we have each week
in that program a global classroom we're
about 25 universities around the world
get on videoconference together it's
8:00 a.m. in New York when we start 8:00
p.m. in Beijing and 20 campuses around
the world
Queen and we have a some world luminary
that participates from some part of the
world talking to all of the students and
then a group discussion that is truly a
worldwide discussion and reminds us very
vividly as vividly as as possible we
need global problem-solving and global
understanding and now with technology
it's just incredible what of course what
can be done so my advice to you truly
honestly haven't had a chance to talk to
each of you individually but if I did I
would tell you this is a great place and
a great opportunity and I'm very very
pleased that you are entering the field
of international public policy and
public administration we need a new kind
of leadership to solve a set of problems
that are really really tough don't come
here for the quiet life you wouldn't get
it at SEPA you won't get it in New York
City you will get a very busy life a
very complicated one you will be exposed
to every range of challenge and problem
you'll be feeling it on a world scale
but frankly I can't think of anything
better so thanks very much and I hope to
see in class in the fall
and I understand if there are any
questions I would be absolutely
delighted to to feel them on anything
come on you're not shy when you email me
I get emails from all of you daily and
you can't ask mr. sacks a question
yeah well I mean just when you think
things that things couldn't get more
complicated of course the the tragedy in
Japan and the Fukushima disaster has
raised the stakes even more because
nuclear is on most lists as part of the
solution to the carbon emissions problem
and it is still on my list but it is on
my list with many more question marks
afterwards we have already in this
country of course 20% of our electricity
coming from nuclear we have some very
problematic sites if we were and China
Japan Korea more than three dozen other
countries in the world our nuclear power
countries and have counted on nuclear
for doing more so if nuclear either
politically or substantively were taken
off the agenda this would be a
horrendously complicated problem I was
just reading a few minutes ago another
one that falls under the same category
probably a lot of you have been
following the the gas hydro fracking
boom that's underway in the United
States there's a lot of hype around it
the fact that now new drilling
techniques allow the shale rock to be
exploded fractured and to release
natural gas and whenever something like
this happens the media reports of of
course are generally almost pure
propaganda because a lot of people have
a lot of money to make and what one
reads and hears in the press is kind of
Gold Rush style reporting rather than
sober assessments well there's a new
study that is about to be released and
it was also I think leaked today that
shows that the greenhouse gas
implications of this natural gas
development are
actually very severe it's usually
thought that methane is cleaner burning
than coal it is in the sense that you're
burning ch4 rather than basically carbon
and so you get more energy per co2
emissions and natural gases therefore
put forward as a transition energy to
something that's truly lower zero carbon
but what this study shows is that the
amount of methane that leaks almost
intrinsically from the way this process
works is very significant and methane
remember is one of the six main
greenhouse gases and so even though the
carbon dioxide side is lower the methane
burden is much higher and it turns out
on a 20-year time horizon according to
this new study which of course has to be
vetted and debated the natural gas
coming from this hydro fracking is
actually worse in its climate change
effect than coal which is pretty
shocking but it shows there is no simple
solution to our problems right now it
shows that kind of media hype and
knowing a tiny bit about something is
not going to get us to the right answers
it shows that unless we have knowledge
based public policy we're really going
to be lost in all of this and it comes
back for me to this unique opportunity
but I think unique responsibilities of
universities to step forward at a time
like this to help sort things out in a
way that is science-based rigorous
unbiased and thinking for the long term
which I think are attributes that
universities can achieve a need to
aspire to please
the question is if I could comment on
the Obama administration's push for a
new direction in global development
especially the Global Health Initiative
basically we're we're in a phase where
we're getting beaten up on on global
development and if it survives the
right-wing onslaught that's underway
right now I'll be impressed there were
in the agreements that were reached in
the last few days some what looks like
possibly serious cuts in the development
budget something's protected it's very
hard to read these line items as I was
doing a couple of hours ago to
understand exactly what's in them but I
don't think we're at the end of the
story we have a head of the Foreign
Affairs Committee in the house who came
in and said that she's out to slash the
foreign assistance budget and I have no
doubt that she means it and I think it's
an extremely serious problem the irony
of course is that were at a time where
absolutely phenomenal things can be done
because our technologies have gotten
better global or governance in
low-income settings in many places is
very impressive and we can do a great
deal and public health is one of those
areas were in the last 10 years there
actually has been a significant buildup
of fighting malaria aids TB with the
tremendous amount of success despite
what doomsayers and skeptics and cynics
said ten years ago so I want to
characterize unfortunately the Obama
administration's position as being
highly proactive they are maybe making
small adjustments on the margin it's
ironic for me
President Bush actually was the one that
built up these public health programs
let me just put it delicately I would
not have bet on that but there was a
very strong religious constituency
within the Republican Party and they
really pushed it action
and that's where those programs came
from I I was in the white house watching
these things close up I was amazed at
how things worked
strangely enough both the Clinton era
and the Obama era have not been dynamic
periods and development aid and in fact
we're kind of holding on or even slight
decline right now there there could be
some adjustments on the margin but one
of the things I'm spending a lot of time
on right now is trying to look for and
work with new donors in the world it's
part of this changing world if one looks
only to the US and to Europe you're
still looking to a 20th century
structure whereas the biggest gusher of
money in the world today by far as the
Middle East first of all so we're
dealing with the number of middle-east
countries and and institutions that want
to step forward as new donors with the
Korean government which has become a
donor recently with China which is now
just about Africa's biggest donor in
infrastructure investment and I think
one of the really interesting aspects of
Development Assistance is whether as the
shape of geopolitics changes the shape
of this development effort can also
change effectively alongside it and
interestingly I the the south-south
cooperation is not only a gimmick but
actually it has some really tangible
important elements to it and I'll just
end the answer with the an example we
had a major company working with
Ericsson in Nnamani villages and it's a
wonderful partner in the connectivity
and the information technology and they
came with the new solution for low-cost
connectivity of primary and lower
secondary schools really a clever set of
technologies both hardware and software
and I was I was pretty dazzled by what
they showed us and they said yes you
know we we got this from India we
acquired this Indian company which is
rolling this out in
in Indian communities and it impressed
me that this was a case absolutely of
technology transfer but coming from
India to Sweden and then back to Africa
so it's really in India to Africa
innovation step which I think we're
gonna see a lot of in the future so I
always hope from for more from the White
House there are a lot of my friends and
colleagues and students there but
because of the budget squeeze and and
all of the rest it's a very difficult
period actually maybe one more please
well one of the so the question is how
do we finance the the future of climate
change mitigation and adaptation am i
optimistic not exactly right now
anything on Finance I'm somewhere
between mildly pessimistic and ready to
because this is such a difficult period
basically so many of our governments
including this one are just intent on
giving tax cuts for the rich and
squeezing programs that are needed by
the rest of society that were you know
chronic budget crisis even at a time of
great private wealth and that has to
make one worry about this in Copenhagen
you'll recall there was the commitment
to a hundred billion dollars of funding
for developing countries for climate
change by the year 2020 but when the
rich countries announced a number 10
years off with no mechanism take the
expected present discounted value nearly
to zero because there isn't anything
behind such a pledge right now and the
question is can you put some politics
some weight behind that to give it some
real oomph I don't know I think that the
way to do this myself would be to levy a
certain number of dollars per ton of
greenhouse gas emitted basically
worldwide and make countries responsible
for the stuff they're putting into the
atmosphere and most countries would
accept that the United States to get
that through the US Congress would be
shocking at this moment and I kind of
urged the world to move forward without
the u.s. because the u.s. is such a
strange creature in a lot of ways that
maybe the world shouldn't be held up by
US politics and move on to its solutions
and then press for the u.s. to join but
right now everything is stalemated on
these issues and when I was looking
through the budget cuts this morning
that were agreed last week don't quote
me on it
because the again these are budget lines
that are hard to understand the way that
so far they've been made public but it
did seem that the us contributions to
the global climate initiatives were cut
and possibly cut significantly in these
line items which is not surprising given
the the position of the Republican Party
in particular but a lot of Democrats as
well who represent : oil States not
wanting to do something on this so this
is very tough and the politics are very
complicated we are entering the 20th
year since the Framework Convention on
Climate Change was signed the US Senate
has not voted one meaningful action in
those twenty years will hit the 20-year
anniversary without anything having been
done after its ratification money is
scarce there's a tremendous oil lobby
that lobbies ferociously against this
this is basically big business interests
not public opinion not science not
anything like that this is where you
really see lobby power at work and coal
and oil are absolutely dead set against
anything happening on climate change and
they have won in this country for 20
years so it's a pretty tough battle and
one of the issues is to help open up the
political space a little bit to
understand what ExxonMobil does what the
Koch brothers do what the Rupert Murdoch
does in in the newspapers and so on
because it's a game almost this kind of
relentless but successful opposition to
any meaningful steps at a time when it's
so obvious scientifically and the data
show it more and more every day that we
are already in the midst of severe
change and there's a lot more to come so
you guys have to get to work fast thanks
a lot
you